what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today actually right
now i'm about to take off to the airport
to go to la for the doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness premiere and
every time i get to go to one of these
premieres i'm just so grateful for this
community and grateful for all the
support that all of you have shown me so
i just wanted to do a video saying thank
you because i know a moment like this is
once in a lifetime and i'm super
grateful for all the support that you
all have given me to allow me to go to
this premiere now just a little heads up
for the channel i am starting a podcast
i'm really excited about it um it's just
going to be called the cosmic wonder
it's going to be on youtube it's going
to be on apple podcast and spotify it's
already up on apple and spotify um it's
a really old episode that i did with the
real rejects if you want to take if you
want to check it out the first episode
is going to drop thursday it's going to
be an in-depth discussion on
multiverse of madness that will contain
spoilers so i'm just warning everybody
right now it's going to have some
spoilers in it but be sure to check it
out on thursday um like i said youtube
spotify apple i'll also be vlogging the
premiere tonight if you want to follow
me on my personal instagram account it's
just cosmic warren that's the handle and
again i'm so grateful and i'm really
excited and i can't wait to see what
this movie is like i'm sure it's gonna
be fantastic and i hope you all enjoy it
as much as i
think i'm gonna enjoy it a lot so as
always thank you all so much for your
support i love you all three thousand
woof